ukraine says this russian-flagged cargo
ship the shibek zoli is transporting
stolen grain it accuses russia of
illegally taking about 4 500 tons from
its occupied port of bagransk
now anchored in the black sea off
turkey's karasu port kiev is asking
ankara to seize the vessel and make
arrests what russia is doing is blocking
our seaports stealing our grain trying
to
impose its wheel on turkey and other
states and this is just what they do in
intention is creating a mess
tons of grains is stuck in ukrainian
ports with exports blocked by russian
forces
russia denies its stealing from sea's
territories and analysts say diplomacy
will have little effect it will be very
hard to reach any agreement between
moscow and kiev on grain export because
there are a lot of practical issues
first of all related to the port of
odessa
but western leaders have accused russia
of using food and hunger as weapons of
war it again not only creates potential
shortages in countries in north africa
and middle east
that can least afford to have food
shortages at this point in time
creates the the risk of additional
unrest and instability in those
countries
about 25 percent of the world's wheat is
supplied by both russia and ukraine
limited exports have destabilized the
global market causing shortages and
rising prices
suppliers and consumers alike are
feeling the impact of an unstable market
made worse by war
if you're hit by missiles everything all
our crops will burn it's a shame
i made it a point to buy top quality
grain
but it might all go to waste
now the fallout of russia's invasion of
ukraine is playing out along turkey's
coast and ankara's next move will decide
where this issue turns
katie
al jazeera